thema heute frauenquote leute wir sehen
uns in den kommentaren wieder
[Musik]
viele männer sind empört warum wollen
frauen die gleichen rechte wie alle
menschen zehntausende jahre hat der mann
die frau erfolgreich unterdrückt
deswegen kommt die forderung der frauen
nach gleichberechtigung für viele männer
jetzt etwas plötzlich hier mal kurz die
krassesten fakten 69 prozent der
bundestagsabgeordneten sind männer
80 prozent der experten im fernsehen
sind männer 92 prozent aller
oberbürgermeister sind männer
also hier aus meiner perspektive sieht
es nach gleichberechtigung aus außerdem
verdienen frauen weniger und bekommen
nur die hälfte der rente
das erstaunliche ist frauen werden gar
nicht von grund auf benachteiligt
sondern erst wenn es um macht liegt
gucken wir uns das mal vereinfacht an
auf ein pavian felsen die mehrheit aller
abiturienten und studenten sind frauen
aber je höher man kommt in einer
hierarchie desto weniger frauen gibt es
es ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass frauen
an die spitze kommen aber oben wird die
luft dünn warum ist das so
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis stand
menschen stellen die ein die einem
ähnlich sind das muss keine aktive
diskriminierung sein
es ist ein unbewusster prozess bayern
vorstände stellen keine dortmund
anhänger ein männer selten frauen warum
gibt es trotzdem noch leute die gegen
die frauenquote sind gemeint ist weil
die frauenquote sichtbar macht dass
frauen benachteiligt werden werden
frauen umso mehr benachteiligt der das
glaubt sagt bei einem brennenden haus
auch ich sollte die bewohner nicht
darauf aufmerksam machen dass ihr haus
brennt nachher fühlen sie sich als
brandopfer diskriminiert
die frauenquote benachteiligt nicht die
männer sie beendet nur die
benachteiligung von frauen
88 in deutschen dax vorständen sind
männer 2015 waren weniger frauen in dax
vorständen als männer mit den namen
thomas und andreas vereinfacht gesagt
sind also ganz oben in der deutschen
wirtschaft neun von zehn pavian männlich
und das obwohl auf dem hügel vielmehr
weibchen mitarbeiten männer obergrenzen
sind nicht nur deswegen sinnvoll weil
kompetente frauen endlich die position
kriegen die ihnen auch zu stehen sondern
auch weil dadurch weniger inkompetente
männer in führungspositionen landen und
da stimmt wenn pavian männchen die ganze
zeit pavian weibchen von krisen
schmeißen und die paviane polizei dann
eingreift beschränkt ist die männchen in
ihrer freiheit
97 prozent der befragten unternehmen
lehnen eine gesetzliche frauenquote ab
männer geführte unternehmen die gegen
frauenquoten sind mich hat es überrascht
ebenfalls überraschend fand ich das in
der geschichte 100 prozent aller könige
der einführung der demokratie kritisch
sahen die freiheit des 1
es immer auch die einschränkung des
anderen wenn ich in meiner beziehung die
freiheit habe auszuschlafen schränkt das
meine freundin ein weil sie dann nicht
schlagzeug üben kann wenn meine freundin
sich die freiheit nimmt schlagzeug zu
üben kann ich nicht ausschlafen
das war ein trauriges beispiel weil ich
keine beziehung haben
immerhin kann ich ausschlafen ich habe
mir schon mal beim aufstehen die bänder
gerissen und musste danach an krücken
laufen
brücken sind scheiße aber im vergleich
zum umfallen sind krücken cool die
frauenquote macht keinen spaß aber wenn
frauen dadurch die macht bekommen die
ihnen zusteht sollte man sie überall
einführen
einfach aus liebe